c
обличчя людей і пікірує донбасом
віце-прем'єр Росії Дмитро Козак то
заступники міністр економіки то фінанси
за галон до роботи так дзвінок від
тіньового уряду донбасу створ ногу в
москве сир цього
за лучину п'є російських міністерств і
жадібно вас апарати та стас донецька та
луганська
призначаючи газета bild ви викидень
залишати дуги думаєш диво рішень і
кіу хвалитися на найвищому рівні в
Москві їжі на Україні циклі був
злочинниць з битної килима до
наркотичного концерну dtx що накласти
або варіння ахматове
шеф-кухаря битний браво активно навчаючись у
одні з робочої групи виконного в
дуракові функцію авто розслідування bild
упевнень сем покриттям вуста точно по
клану край ілюзії пит називаю мінську
будинкової насті росії вже давно ви
значилося з владним та планом ще до
донбасу та вибір наук надія
території тепла не входить і форум у
магазах пеклі передати їм до України
білокаменську до молодості свд треба
абсурду колима видно стіні технічніше
чиновники про довідкові російські
політики до-рую донбасом вибори на
донбасі не маю цін судіть до нас о 1 годині
про про і данилку паван їх території
друзів знайдіть
москвою так повністю до районів
вимикається на нього один мільярд карбованців
широкий вкаже bild визнання за кермо але
ванга донбасу до що в цьому та дарів ніж
то пак і рівним і ту кремль досягнуто
сина україна
думаю струкова дестабілізована чопів
тіла не мінську до молодості і мало успіху
потрібного політичними методами можна
його через санте так над малюнком на
росію щоб вона видна волосся вигляд
владних плані в чидо данн башти і на
донбас
журналістські розслідування на
політичному уріні шини їжу козам
провалу мінських домовленостей
у team автор матеріалу заповнюючи
документи для управління донбасом з
кремля перевіряв і вище журналісти
червоний спецслужби 2 краєм я до них самий
bild не раз калоші та